ha sido tal la debacle de la izquierda
en estas elecciones municipales y
regionales que el presidente del
gobierno Pedro Sánchez ha asumido esta
derrota de manera personal asegura que
los resultados van mucho más allá de lo
local o de lo regional y que lo mejor y
cito textualmente es que los españoles
tomen la palabra para definir el rumbo
político del país y es que el 28 m como
se le dice aquí a la fecha electoral 28
de mayo tiñó de azul el mapa de España
un azul que representa al partido de
derecha partido popular que obtuvo el
31,5% de los votos un 3% más que el psoe
aproximadamente
750 mil votos lo que hace cambiar la
tendencia de las elecciones de 2019
cuando la izquierda resultó vencedora en
cantidad de votos se hace con al menos
seis regiones que estaban antes en manos
de la izquierda entre ellas la comunidad
valenciana y la mayoría de las grandes
ciudades españolas excepto Barcelona que
aún está en disputa el partido de
ultraderecha vox normaliza su presencia
en la política Española y recibió un 7%
de los votos en las municipales Un
aumento de presencia que aumenta las
posibilidades de pactar gobiernos de
coalición Precisamente en estas regiones
con el partido popular y que pues eso
afianza esta presencia del partido de
ultraderecha en los gobiernos y
parlamentos regionales la vicepresidenta
segunda de España y ministra de trabajo
Yolanda Díaz Que formó hace unos meses
en abril la formación progresista sumar
a reaccionado y ha valorado
este resultados diciendo que el mensaje
de anoche fue muy claro y que ASUME el
reto de hacer las cosas distintas ella
tiene el
progresismo de España tiene muchas
esperanzas puestas en ella que además
ahora mismo es la política mejor
valorada del país